[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who's
just like thor
because i love to get hammered off white
lightning very british joke to open the
video with
and in this breakdown we're going to be
going over the theory that lady loki
might not be who you think she is
first introduced in loki episode 2 it
seemed like she was indeed a gender swap
version of the god of mischief from an
alternate timeline
however we do know some things that
could contradict this
and throughout this video we're gonna be
going through the evidence to support
that she's another marvel character
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend you
turn off now
make sure you like the video if you
enjoy it and don't forget to subscribe
to never miss a trick
cha-cha without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
video
okay so the mysterious variant of loki
is someone who has plagued the tva
throughout the first two episodes of the
brand new disney plus series
she's wiped out several minutemen teams
and is causing havoc across the sacred
timeline by creating several nexus
events
episode 2 ended with loki in the tva
going to the rox court disaster
to locate the character we discovered
that she'd been hiding out at
apocalyptic events in order to avoid
detection
and after mobius [ __ ] mobius
tracked her down due to kablooey being
sold at this location
the team closed in loki came face to
face with her
and though she shared several mannerisms
man you're tripping
well if you think that's definitely lady
loki i've watched the episode several
times
picked over all the little clues in it
and i believe that this is actually
another character from the marvel
universe
that's called sylvie now firstly in
order to discuss this theory we have to
take a big step back and look at the
show's cast
episode 2 showcased that there are
several versions of loki running around
and this includes things like a tour de
france winner and ones that the hulk
wouldn't call
so puny therefore we know that out in
the timeline there are several versions
of the character
knocking about we know from the trailers
that we at least meet a king loki ruler
of asgard version
as well as a vote loki one who did
appear in his own comic run
now speaking of comics if you're
familiar with loki agent of asgard
then you will know that we deal with a
brand new young version of loki that is
trying to right the wrongs of his past
however he is haunted by a future
version of himself
a much older loki that torments him at
every point
we know from imdb that richard e grant
will be featuring in the show
and personally i believe that this is an
old version of loki
however i will say cast lists can never
be fully trusted as one division had
people like james spade enlisted
but i do think that he will be in the
series when speaking with total film
head writer michael waldron said the
following when discussing whether he
would be in it or not
nobody wants to hear me say who richard
e grant is playing
we're lucky to have him in the show if
he's in the show
i heard he might be so i think everyone
should just watch and find out
like loki himself we really wanted the
experience of watching the show to feel
kind of unexpected
and constantly shape-shifting so i kind
of
kind of played your hand early on there
and i think the bit about them being
lucky to have him in the show
is only something that you would say if
he was turning up however our theory
does kinda hinge on him
appearing and being an older version of
loki but we'll discuss that later on
now back to the lady and if you watch
the english version of the show
then you may have seen in the credits
that sofia di martino was listed as
being a character called variant
however in international versions this
was translated to read out selfie
in case you don't know who sylvia is she
actually went on to take the title
enchantress
no not that one now as a child sylvie
woke up one day to find out that she had
been given incredible powers
this included several abilities such as
telekinesis
possession mind control and the ability
to cast spells
these are all things that we've seen
loki do and interestingly
lady loki do as well now sylvie ended up
joining the avengers and
over time she started speaking with an
asgardian accent
which just so happens to be the same
that i have
so as you know it's all connected
now early on in her career sylvie really
made her mark
and everything seemed to be going her
way no one suspected anything was off
and she quickly became a valued member
of the team however it was revealed that
selby was actually given these abilities
by loki
and that he had an overall plan loki had
been effing around one day
and he just decided to take a mortal and
trick them into believing that they were
asgardian
it was a crushing blow and it kind of
robbed sylvie of the position
that she'd worked so hard for the sylvie
was somewhat manipulated
and if our theories are right then
potentially she may have been picked by
an older loki to be his plaything
in the comics sylvie was born in
oklahoma and as we know from the ending
of episode 1
she has been to this location
potentially she might have even lived
there as a child
and have been visited by a time traveler
earlier in her life
this would be how she knew to travel
back there to strike at the tva
when they were sending out a team to
investigate because this event would
have always occurred in the timeline
then a younger version of her at home
would have been there to witness it
and could have found her own way to
travel through time with what the tva
left behind
the reset charge never went off and thus
these events
would remain completely unchanged
perhaps she met loki when she was
younger
and he gave her the abilities we see her
wielding an episode too
he might have even tricked her into
believing that she was a variant of him
and she could be trying to destroy the
tva loki has the ability to implant
vault's memories
and sylvie actually experience things
like this in the comic books
now other evidence that suggests this is
that the characters look quite similar
sylvie in the comics is blonde much like
sophia
yes it's a reach however all the other
loki's we've seen so far outside of her
possess the long black hair that he's
famous for
so the fact that it's changed for her
does seem a bit
strange she also tells loki not to call
her loki
which further lends itself to this
theory when going through files we can
see her name is sylvie laufey's daughter
which in icelandic culture is what you
name your daughter hinting that she may
be an amalgamation of loki and sylvie
now i know i said before you shouldn't
pay too much attention to cast lists as
they can be hit and miss
but currently it is listed on imdb that
kaylee fleming is playing a young selfie
this was posted long before the show
dropped so it seems weird that someone
would pre-empt the theory
thus what if the biggest trick that loki
pulled was making us think that selfie
was actually him
i think it would make a lot of sense
going off what we know and it just seems
like the most likely thing
due to all the evidence interestingly in
the comics when we're first introduced
to lady loki
it was because the events of ragnarok
had led to the spirits of the asgardians
being displaced
loki ended up going into a body that was
intended for sif
and thus he took on a female form female
formers
is this the best script we've got and no
dma anyway
it's also possible that loki's spirit
may have entered sylvie's body
instead of sith potentially this could
be the version of loki that was killed
in infinity war
as it happened right after ragnarok and
i think that it would be quite
interesting to see a version that we
come to know over the series
going head-to-head with a version that
we know from the films now this is of
course a fan theory
so we don't know for definite and might
be wildly wrong
but there's some evidence here to
support that something is off
loki should never be taken at face value
and who knows
we might just be scratching the surface
here now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on these theories so make sure
you comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase 3 box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the episode which will
be linked on screen right now
we've gone over everything in episode 2
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
out of the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been poor
i'll see you next time take care peace